زلزل تركيا لم يتسبب فقط في تصدع المباني
وانما تسبب في تصدع جدار الثقه الذي يربط
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بالشارع فكلما مرت
الايام على الكارثه ووصلت فرق الانقاذ
عملها تزايدت اعداد ضحاياها وبالتالي زادت
سهام النقد الشعبي الموجهه لاردوغان
والحكومه وعلى راسها غياب سرعه الاستجابه
للزلزال العنيف وهي انتقادات لم يستسلم
اردوغان لها كعادته لكنه كذلك لم يستطع ان
ينكرها
بالطبع هناك ثغرات في عمليات الاستجابه
الاوليه من المستحيل الاستعداد لكارثه
كهذه يتعين على الناس الاستماع فقط الى
رسائل السلطات وتجاهل المحرضين رساله
اردوغان لمواطنه لم تمتص كل الغضب على ما
يبدو فذكريات الزلزال الذي وقع عام
1999 ما محاضره في الاذهان بضحاياها الذين
قاربوا العشرين الفا وحتى اتهامات الفساد
التي كانت في ذلك التاريخ عادت لتتكرر
اليوم وبالاخص من قبل اهالي المنطقه
المنكوبه غازي عنتاب
شركه البناء القت بقطع خرسانيه لتراعي
شروط البناء الانشاءات لم تكن تحت اشراف
الدوله فمات الكثير من الناس بسبب عدم
وجود رقبه فاين انشال تايمز سلطت الضوء
على قرارات بالعفو بحق نحو 75 الف مبنى
سكني بنيت بالمخالفه لقواعد انظمه الزلازل
التي كانت الحكومه قد اشترطتها والاخطر ان
الحكومه كانت تنوي ايضا اصدار عفو لعدد
اخر من المباني قبل الزلزال بايام وهناك
رقم يحير الاتراك 36 مليار دولار جمعتها
الحكومه ضمن ضرائب فرضت بعد زلزال عام 99
بهدف ت البلاد لاي زلزال قادم تقول
المعارضه ان حجم الدمار يظهر ان هذا
المبلغ الضخم لم يصرف في محله هناك تجربه
اخرى تشكو منها المعارضه فبعد كل حادثه
تزيد فيها الانتقادات للحكومه على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي تحدث مشكلات في الدخول
الى هذه المواقع لكن هذه المره من حرم من
استخدامها لم يكن المعارضون فقط وانما بعض
المحاصرين تحت الانقاض والذين كانوا
يحاولون بث رسائل عن انهم احياء وارشاد
فرق الانقاذ لمواقعهم عن السمان العربيه